you did ads for the British butter  council no yes I did  no I did you know yes no I did not yes  it ended up that way what I did was I  did adverts for a British butt or a  company called country life and and it  took over and the adverts had such a  major impact on on them on the button  market I created in England butter wars  you know I was challenged even like a  and I loved flying on Air New Zealand  for instance right because it was cheap  but they started to give me problems  because they were saying New Zealand  butter is better this is what Johnny  Rotten faced in his life you used to  stand on so much more you used to stand  for anarchy in the UK if you want that  much butter you're not standing any  longer I did in that period war  ballooned out and I really enjoyed the  product but thank God it wasn't sending  through napkins I was promoting ok I'd  still be pulling your mail  [Applause]  you